who's most likely to be found at the  bottom of the LA River  during the Turk Turk cruise in the craft  team they actually put my chair right by  lady tree down the front ladies  generally I think ya know the guys show  up two hours later because patriarchy  Terry's primary Oh Terry  oh this set is a prank sanctuary  pranking us she's breaking please guys  I'm Frank Ennis it's just an all-day  thing Frank we're prank of files right  now that's having Dirk went a little too  far he set the whole set on fire we  don't know exactly  so that was intense god I've fallen off  this season a little bit  yeah I'd say season three it's children  yeah I was me yeah we shifted positions  I started strong and then this season  I've really started losing it a lot more  frequently  Terry yeah married 25 years no one's  annoying cross